♪ [upbeat music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how BigQuery ML
can enable you to build
machine learning models quickly.
BigQuery ML lets you operationalize
machine learning models
right within BigQuery,
using standard SQL.
ML usually requires extensive programming
and knowledge of specialized frameworks,
but BigQuery ML empowers you
to use your existing SQL skills
to build and use machine learning models
in under 10 minutes,
saving you from exporting data
and managing ML infrastructure.
It supports running models
on petabyte scale data
in a fraction of the time.
It can also handle preprocessing
like splitting data,
one-hot encoding, and normalization.
And it comes with support
from many types of ML models
and so much more.
You can even use AutoML tables
to create best-in-class models
while handling feature engineering
and model selection.
To set up BigQuery ML,
create the dataset in BigQuery
and just write a simple SQL query
with the create model clause
to create the model.
Execute the query to run
and observe the model
as it's being trained
in the Model Stats tab.
From there, you can use your trained model
to make predictions,
using the ML Predict function
in a new query,
and enjoy the results directly
in the BigQuery console.
Just like that.
BIgQuery ML democratizes
predictive analytics
and makes it easier for anyone
to get started with ML.
It's being used for anomaly detection,
customer segmentation,
product recommendations,
predictive forecasting, and more.
So, next time you want to build models
using your BigQuery data,
take a minute to look at BigQuery ML.
To learn more check out
cloud.google.com/BigQuery-ML
♪ [music] ♪